so adam corolla is a comedian he'll be
up on stage this weekend in indianapolis
and we hope he's got security he joins
us tonight i'm carl thanks so much for
coming on so if you you can it's pretty
easy to take the core question here is
abortion what should we do about it but
this decision basically says hey guys go
vote on it because it's a democracy why
don't you decide
and the response from a lot of people on
the left is
shut up i'm going to hurt you what do
you make of this
well it's been pretty effective i mean
if you look at the last couple of years
you look at blm you look at all the
riots
they've essentially got their way i mean
they'd be kind of foolish not to go back
to that playbook i mean look at covid
look at anyone who disagreed with
anything they said any doctor that
disagreed with anything they said anyone
who tweeted something that was different
from their normative views they were
thrown off so
we have let their tactics be
effective i mean i talk to comedians
every day and they're like i think about
the jokes before i say them the audience
i worry about
it's been effective so they're going to
keep going with it as long as we let
them keep going with it and it keeps
being effective
well sure i mean if you let your kids
spray paint your living room they
probably keep doing it why didn't
someone think of that when we allowed a
small group of of angry people to torch
our cities
i don't know i mean you know if you
really think about a stand-up club like
a comedy club it is the town square you
know we always sort of talk about the
digital town square that is twitter but
a stand-up club is a town square a
person gets up on a three-foot riser and
amplifies their voice and shares their
opinions
and we somehow decided the town square
was an antiquated idea or if whoever had
the microphone said something they
disagreed with i mean i now do shows and
people in the audience are disagreeing
out loud they're giving their opinion
out loud that never existed in the past
you were the audience i was a comedian
you sat and listened you got a two-drink
minimum i said my jokes
their people are in bold now and it's
like the same thing that's happening on
comedic stages is really happening on
commercial airline flights like people
are now somehow feeling like they can
physically put their hands on other
people they disagree with
man that is not that is the president we
want to stop and you'd think the
democracy defenders would be opposed to
it but of course they're for it weird
adam crowley appreciate you coming on
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight